qui aurait cru qu'un jour la dame de fer
birmane la farouche la dissidente quand
tu admirais irait devant les tribunaux
nié les accusations de génocide
faute d'accord les factures
malheureusement dit elle des faits
énoncés par la gambie sont faux
incomplet et trompeurs de vendée
victimes présumées jetant dessus janos
failli arrêter le génocide dit le
ministre de la justice gambienne
c'est au nom de 57 pays musulmans que la
gambie a porté la cause d'héroïne gars
devant les tribunaux viols meurtres
torture la gambie accuse la birmanie de
violer la convention de 1948 sur le
génocide en volant exterminer la
minorité musulmane depuis le mois d'août
2010 est près de 800000 euros un gars se
sont réfugiés au bangladesh
fuyant les exactions de l'armée birmane
et des milices bouddhistes les
militaires birmans nous ont torturés dit
hamida katun ils ont violé des femmes
nos filles je me suis enfui je me suis
caché pendant 12 jours avant d'arriver
au bangladesh voulons que justice soit
faite pour les massacres et les viols
commis par l'armée birmane dia si nab et
goom
nous voulons que le monde entier le
sache mais la lauréate du prix nobel de
la paix de 91 est imperturbable elle qui
s'opposaient jadis à la junte militaire
birmane est aujourd'hui à leurs côtés si
des crimes de guerre ont été commis par
des membres de l'armée birmane dit elle
ils seront poursuivis par le tribunal
militaire conformément à notre
constitution
elle compare la fuye d'héroïne gâte non
pas un génocide
mais un exode comme celui des serbes de
croatie je vois un grand problème pour
madame chipie à pouvoir convaincre le
reste du monde que ce qui est arrivé à
rakhine ce qui est arrivé au hangar
n'est pas de tout un janot c'est mais
tout simplement à une différence
d'opinion entre quelqu'un encore
aujourd'hui les persécutions se
poursuivre selon ce spécialiste
la violence continue didier l'héroïne
gars n'ont pas la liberté de mouvement
il ajoute il faut que la cour
internationale de justice agisse la
gambie réclame des mesures d'urgence
pour les 600000 rohingya qui sont
toujours en birmanie aung san suu kyi
elle voit son image internationale de
plus en plus ternie ici à 0 2 les girls
10 radio canada montréal